you mentioned that sam
is a former u.s champion she also
mentioned that he's a gold medalist from
the olympiad as well as the author of a
couple of books and he's doing chess
videos and the like pretty accomplished
career so far sam uh to
tell us about your tournament will you
assess how you played here um i it's
funny i cannot remember playing this
badly in a very long time but somehow i
still managed to like put points on the
scoreboard and have a 2700 performance
but i think about everything i did wrong
like my sense of danger completely
eluded me against maxine when i was just
like one move away from a draw a lot of
trivially lost pawn ending
uh i
jeffrey played the troll accelerated
dragon against me i got a plus two
position and didn't beat him uh i missed
the one and two moves against dominguez
yesterday uh i was worse with white
against mama jarov after like five moves
i think i just did absolutely everything
wrong this tournament but
it's a very good sign that if you're
really really off forum and just playing
really really badly that you're still
you know breaking even on rating that's
a sign that you've probably got stronger
that's a very good way to look at it uh
how does this prep you for your
tournaments to come uh well it's a great
event i mean i think this is probably
the second strongest tournament i've
ever played after like and say i'm sort
of disappointed to have made minus one
but uh it's far from a disaster you know
it's of
be playing against a higher rated field
and with an extra black i think when
breaking even rating-wise it's fine um
but it was just it was a good experience
to play an event like this i would
certainly love to play more it's very
rare for me to get an opportunity like
this when i really appreciate the
invitation and you know i wish i could
have put up a better result what is your
next tournament i'll play a european
club well first i'll be back here for
960. uh but next like classical chess
event is european club cup and then back
here again for us championship so
there's definitely some some good events
coming up that i'm looking forward to
appreciating the shifts back to
classical chess absolutely i mean
there's but
both in terms of face-to-face and in
terms of the time control i've said that
in terms of my ability to calculate i
actually think i do best on a 3d board
second best blindfolded and third best
on a 2d board like when i was playing
these online events and find myself
staring into space at some point like
the arbiters were saying like what the
hell are you looking at like
but um
yeah that uh that and also just it being
slower and like more
you know the kind of training i do
really works for classical and is kind
of useless in blitz so just notice my my
head's just not that fast and if for
example something if my reflexes or
reaction time is like a tenth of a
second slower than everyone else is in
classical that totally doesn't matter
and rabbit it probably doesn't even
matter either but in blitzwell you saw
what happened
so uh yeah i'm just i'm glad classical
chess is coming back and yeah
all right well we look to seeing you
seeing you again in chess 960 that's
coming up really shortly yeah get
yourself that'll be a lot of fun all
right we'll see you soon sam i have a
question for you if you please uh these
uh really great elite tournaments where
you have 2 800 2700 players and the mix
of these players often
opening theory is a very important
advantage in these events and coming out
of the opening with advantages
overall this sinkhole cup did you see it
as a theoretical battle because
i think of you as a really great
theoretician and how do you think about
opening theory and whether this
tournament advanced it or not there's
definitely i don't know i mean there's
some games that are more important than
others like what jeffrey did against me
was nonsense what i did against linear
was nonsense like there's just certain
things that are just not
like not good uh then people take some
liberties and that's fine but there's
definitely like a lot of
preparation that goes into it but
ultimately it's the game play i think of
the preparation i did here the best uh
prepared the best game i had was with
maxim where i was just better with black
out of the opening and then i managed to
lose because he had played me
and he just played better but i don't
know i mean
this tournament i just sort of told
myself i'm going to play every game like
there's no tomorrow i ended up playing
multiple night offs i played the scotch
i did all sorts of aggressive things and
then finally today i thought maybe i'll
do something just a little bit more
sedates but then he just prepared well
and i got absolutely nowhere so maybe i
should have
kept going nuts even more all right
thank you very much sam and good luck on
your future events we'll be seeing you
in the 960 as well as the u.s
championships big events as sam saying
coming up